on en apprend plus sur un collègue au
bureau en jouant une heure avec lui à
n'importe quel jeu idéalement un jeu de
société ou même un sport qu'on en
apprend en une heure de collaboration au
travail entre les réunions et la machine
à café
le jeu est un formidable test de
personnalité
c'est probablement le meilleur quand on
joue c'est très instinctif ce qui peut
ressortir d'un jeu est très instinctif
dis moi à quoi tu joues et je te dirai
qui tu es montre moi ce kit stimule et
quels sont les récompenses que tu veux
aller chercher des gratifications qui
veut aller chercher dans un jeu et je
ferai rapidement le parallèle entre ta
vie de joueur est à vis de travailleurs
d'employés entrepreneurs etc
les parallèles sont flagrants on est
tous des joueurs je prends le jeu au
sens très large du terme
on a tous une proportion jeu qui est
naturel qui est instinctif par exemple
qui parmi vous à jouer à un jeu sur son
smartphone dans les dernières 24 heures
lever le doigt
dites moi qu'est j'ai un petit 20 %
comme ça à vue d'oeil
ok maintenant ti parmi vous a été sur
facebook dans les dernières 24 heures ok
là on approche plus de 80 90 % alors
scoop pour vous facebook c'est un jeu
c'est un jeu social
ce que vous retrouverez dans facebook
peut se retrouver dans un jeu par
exemple dans facebook vous avez un score
il porte pas son nom il s'appelle pas
score mais lorsque vous publiez quelque
chose et que vous attendez des likes sur
votre publication
c'est un score comme dans un jeu et vous
pouvez avoir un bon à moyen ou un très
mauvais score dans facebook vous avez
une notion de niveaux que vous retrouvez
également dans beaucoup de jeu lorsque
vous atteignez comme certains dans la
salle 5000 amis sur facebook
vous ne pouvez plus rester dans ce stade
là vous passés au niveau 2 et vous devez
avoir une page artistes stars célébrités
etc
dans un jeu vidéo c'est level up c'est
la même chose on est tous des joueurs
enfants adultes personnes âgées hommes
femmes
ouvriers employés cadres on est tous des
joueurs
malheureusement ou heureusement pour
nous on a tendance encore trop souvent
résumée le jeu a une activité pour
jeunes adultes ou pour enfants
c'est très bien moi ça me va puisque
j'adore prendre comme exemple les
enfants et leurs comportements pour
transposer ce qu'ils font à des
activités d'adultes dans un cadre
professionnel
les enfants sur des joueurs naturel
décomplexé il joue de manière très
professionnelle en fait c'est leur
activité principale
un enfant de 10 ans aujourd'hui dans nos
pays développés va jouer à plus de 15
jeux différents sur la même journée tous
les jours tous les jours qu'un jeu
différent donc sa vie et son quotidien
est rythmé par le jeu c'est ce qui rend
probablement pour lui ou pour elle
encore plus difficile aujourd'hui le
reste entre les quinze jeux sur la
journée je dois aller à l'école
je dois à 18h30 maman m'a fait des choux
de bruxelles
je n'aime pas ça j'ai ma journée est
entrecoupé d'activités qui sont pas
ludique au départ et bien c'est ça qu'on
appelle la gamification ou la
ludification pour nos cousins québécois
la gamification c'est la transposition
de techniques de jeu dans un
environnement qui n'est pas ludique qui
n'est pas stimulant pour créer la
stimulation
je vais prendre un autre exemple prenons
julie julie apprend à se brosser les
dents qui pour les parents qui sont dans
la salle faire en sorte que ses enfants
se brosse les dents correctement c'est
un vrai challenge
en fait c'est un triple challenge il
faut qu'ils se brosse les dents
régulièrement deux fois par jour trois
fois par jour il faut qu'ils se brosse
les dents deux minutes entières bonne
chance et quand vous avez atteint 7,2
challenge qui sont déjà pas mal
il faut encore qu'on se brosse les dents
correctement c'est à dire dans chaque
coin de la bouche et sur toutes les
dents et julie ça lui plaît pas du tout
fait ce truc c'est un moment sa
motivation est extrait 1 sec
si elle ne le fait pas et il y aura des
conséquences négatives sera gronder
c'est la motivation devrait être
intrasèque je vous montre par exemple
voilà l'exemple de gamification sens le
plus strict du terme
julie elle a oublié qu'elle se brosser
les dents elle joue elle joue elle est
dans le jeu et dans le score et c'est sa
motivation devient intrinsèque 4 joue
pour le jeu et se brosse les dents pour
le jeu ces petites certains qui
s'appelle cube qui va grandir qui
s'appelle colibri qui est à paris sont
ils sont excellents on est dans le
quotidien mais le quotidien des enfants
c'est quoi c'est surtout l'école et s'il
ya bien un domaine où il ya du travail à
faire en justement en l'édification
c'est l'apprentissage et c'est les
écoles pour les enfants et pour les
adultes
aujourd'hui quand vous participez à des
conférences ça ressemble encore à ceux
ci physique je suis là je suis tout seul
sur une scène je vous dis style mon
savoir je me réponds et vous vous êtes
passif en train de m'écouter
super je pense que je peux faire un
effort mais je vous tiendrais pas en
haleine 2 heures 3 heures et les enfants
doivent passer une journée comme ça donc
dans l'apprentissage
la gamification a toute sa place et je
vais dire dans l'autre sens le le
meilleur moyen d'apprendre quelque chose
c'est le jeu c'est la meilleure
technique on apprenait on a tous joué à
des jeux d'apprentissage des animaux
jouent à des jeux d'apprentissage
donc il répète des rites qui sont des
jeux qui pourra prendre en fait à
devenir un adulte
pourquoi est-ce que l'apprentissage par
le jeu ça fonctionne parce que dans le
jeu le feedback est immédiat si vous
faites un progrès dans un jeu on vous le
dit tout de suite et normalement vous
valorisez survalorise donc vous êtes en
progression vous êtes au courant vous
êtes en progression moi je rêve d'avoir
dans ma voiture sur mon gps un écran qui
de la gendarmerie qui m'envoie une
petite félicitations en me disant ça
fait trois ans qu'on n'a pas pris de pv
ça arrivera un jour ça arrivera un jour
et donc c'est à 17 indicateurs de
progression c'est un des moteurs c'est
une vertu principale du jeu jouer c'est
progresser de manière visible
et malheureusement ou heureusement que
c'est notre chance par rapport à
d'autres activités c'est que dans les
entreprises
vos progrès ne sont pas valorisées en
temps réel et vous n'avez pas de
feedback ou trop peu en temps réel sur
une progression beaucoup trop peu il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire là dessus
la deuxième vertu du jeu je voudrais
partager avec vous aujourd'hui c'est
l'existence de règles alors ça c'est un
peu aujourd'hui c'est le thème c'est
rébellion mais dans un jeu bien fait la
première chose à faire c'est de définir
un règlement pour que le jeu fonctionne
et que les joueurs soient motivés et
appliqués
il faut qu'il y ait des règles c'est
très rassurant c'est très stimulant
c'est très motivant c'est très juste
c'est très transparent dans la vie
réelle malheureusement nous n'avons pas
cette chance
les règles soit elles ne sont pas
connues soit elles existent carrément
pas soit elles existent mais elles sont
complexes ou changeantes ou pas respecté
imaginez quelqu'un qui vous apprend un
jeu et qui est le premier à tricher
parce que tous les joueurs arrêtent
d'arrêter de jouer tout de suite
malheureusement dans la vraie vie on est
toujours obligé de remplir sa
déclaration d'impôts mais regrette le
fait que le mythe du budget ha ha ha et
la dernière version du jeu
it will fight
trop
en famille
plusieurs badauds abri à venir
for my kind
debout watson bus
what is good phreaking faire
je vais vous faire une confession j'ai
toujours rêvé d'être un gros fonds d'un
panda guerrier dans la vie ravi ça va
être difficile donc je peux faire un
effort dont l'embonpoint mais pour
redevenir un panda c'est compliqué la
vertu que j'essaie de vous démontrer ici
c'est la projection dans un jeu on est
un autre soi même ou un meilleur soi
même j'ai pris volontairement un exemple
extrême qui est world of warcraft c'est
un des jeux les plus populaires de jeu
de rôle en ligne
je vais vous prendre un exemple plus
basiques si vous quittez le bureau à 17
heures pour les jouer au tennis avec des
amis à partir du moment où vous aller
enfiler votre tenue de des dix manoudou
men vous êtes le joueur de tennis et
votre historique de joueur de tennis
votre niveau votre score précédent ce
que vous voulez atteindre à ce moment là
fait surface c'est toujours vous mais
c'est vous le joueur de tennis en
entreprise
malheureusement c'est souvent vous vous
vous vous est le même vous et donc les
managers de demain devoir inventer des
scénarios qui vous permettent quand même
de vous projeter dans des fonctions qui
sont changeantes avec des motivations
qui change etc et de d'être parfois des
personnages si vous vous envoie un
séminaire en pologne pour représenter la
société vous êtes l'ambassadeur de la
société ce jour là c'est la première
fois que vous le faites et vous avez un
nouveau rôle à endosser world of
warcraft ce sont aujourd'hui six
millions de joueurs qui payent 15 euros
par brun pour pour jouer à ce jeu est
pour devenir quelqu'un d'autre c'est le
jeu qui a le plus de nolife vous savez
ces gens qui malheureusement quittent la
vie réelle pour tomber et fond dans le
jeu ils sont plus en plus subtile ces
jeux parce que non seulement on peut
personnaliser un personnage mais peut
également aller très loin dans la de la
psychologie du personnage avec tous ces
modules de chat
toutes ces interactions entre joueurs
c'est un peu de moi au niveau de ma
personnalité que je peux mettre d'autres
joueurs et souvent c'est un mois
fantasmer à moi meilleur celui que
j'aurais voulu être dans la vie réelle
pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle de
bordeaux warcraft parce que ce jeu est
utilisé par les experts de gamification
pour justement définir ce qui fonctionne
en entreprise pourquoi parce que c'est
un des rares jeux ou les quatre profils
type de joueur que je vais vous montrer
peuvent s'épanouir dans ce jeu
chacun des quatre profils peut devenir
aller au bout de ce qu'il souhaite
avant de vous parler des quatre profite
je vais vous poser une petite question
donc ça a été inventé par richard bartel
et imaginons une situation vous courrez
tous les dimanches avec des amis un
petit groupe d'amis vous êtes 5 6
personnes vous êtes des sportifs
amateurs vous courrez 5 km votre niveau
n'est pas terrible mais ce jour là il
fait particulièrement beau et un des
amis lance bon écouter et si on faisait
le marathon de barcelone en septembre
dans six mois ou dans 4 - 5 mois et là
tout le monde est de bonne humeur et
donc le tout le monde y va
yes on le fait d'accord donc imaginez
vous dans cette situation qu'est ce qui
à votre avis va vous motiver plus
qu'autre chose est-ce que ce qui vous
motive
ça va être de vaincre les autres qui
sont dans ce groupe vous êtes 5 et vous
voulez être le meilleur du groupe à la
fin à l'issue de ce marathon 1
ou alors vous avez un score en tête vous
voulez finir le marathon où vous voulez
le faire en 3h29 c'est le score que vous
voulez atteindre c'est le timing que
vous voulez atteindre 2 3 ce qui vous
stimule c'est pendant les quatre mois
d'entraînement vous allez faire avec vos
amis
c'est les aventures que vous allez vivre
ensemble donc l'entraînement en lui même
est une motivation ou enfin ce qui vous
motive c'est d'aller à barcelone
vivre en marathon ce que vous n'avez
jamais fait et découvrir barcelone que
vous n'avez jamais vu voilà donc ceux
qui sont sur la première notion donc
vaincre les autres joueurs donc les
autres de membres du groupe lever le
doigt s'il vous plaît c'est difficile a
avoué
ok 10% de la population est censé lever
le doigt
mais elle le fera pas deuxième
possibilité ce qui nous intéresse c'est
d'atteindre un score personnel vous
voulez progresser dans votre niveau de
roeux nord et vous voulez atteindre un
score lever le doigt ok
troisième possibilité vous allez vivre
six mois super stimulant avec vos
copains et vous entraîner à fond et
c'est super à peu près égale hockey et
dernière possibilité découvrir barcelone
découvrir le monde des marathoniens
c'est votre truc
ok donc nous n'avons dans la salle pas
de tueur
j'ai en tout 1 on a à proportion égale
des accompli soeur et désocialise heures
et on a un peu moins d'explorateurs le
tueur dans un jeu c'est quelqu'un qui
est motivée par le classement il veut
surpasser les autres porte bien son nom
si je suis dans un groupe de saintes et
que le groupe de cinq est médiocre
je veux quand même être le meilleur des
médiocres la qualité intrinsèque de ce
qu'on fait ne m'intéresse pas ou peu je
suis très sensible au classement lorsque
je suis un tueur c'est ce qui compte
pour moi
le deuxième profil la complice heures
est intéressé par sa progression en
termes de compétences de savoir faire il
veut progresser dans sa discipline ou
collectionner des expertises dans
plusieurs disciplines
je veux mon brevet de secouriste mon
brevet de pilote d'hélicoptère mon
permis de conduire de camions etc etc je
veux dire bon l'espagnol et fluette dans
deux ans ça c'est la complice heures
excellent dans une équipe d'avoir des
accompli soeur ils sont très sensibles à
la notion de niveau ils peuvent aimer
les classements à condition que les
classements dans un indicateur clair de
progression de qualité de performance
le troisième profil le social isr qui a
majoritaire dans la salle visiblement
qui est également majoritaire de la
population sont des personnes qui dans
un jeu vidéo comme dans la vie réelle
sont d'abord intéressée par les
interactions avec les autres joueurs
ce qui compte c'est mon rôle dans
l'équipe ce qui compte c'est ce que je
vais pouvoir faire pour les autres et
avec les autres c'est ça qui m'intéresse
c'est ça qui motive dans world of
warcraft le social isr va vouloir
rejoindre une guilde étaient en groupe
et il va attendre que le chef de la
guilde lui attribue un rôle
et le dernier profil qui est le pur à
leur art lui par contre c'est
l'explorateur l'explorateur c'est
quelqu'un qui a soif de découvertes qui
veut découvrir de nouveaux territoires
des nouveaux pouvoirs inconnue et c'est
qui est très curieux dans une entreprise
c'est quelqu'un qui va être tourné vers
l'innovation
c'est quelqu'un qui va remettre souvent
à savoir faire acquis en cause et dire
non on devrait réfléchir différemment
très utile aussi en fait les quatre
profils sont très utiles même le tueur
même les tueurs qui sont parmi vous sont
utiles si vous avez une équipe composée
d'un seul profil toutes les études
montrent que c'est insuffisant il faut
un mélange pour un savant mélange si
vous n'avez que des tueurs c'est une
catastrophe
vraiment c'est la graisse la guerre si
vous n'avez que des socialistes heures
parfois on s'écarte de la notion de
performance de l'entreprise de
l'objectif réel est d'accord donc ces
quatre profils sont la base de tout le
travail que nous faisons et c'est dingue
à quel point on peut les découvrir dans
l'activité quotidienne au bureau c'est
incroyable quand vous faites le
parallèle est donc mon message
aujourd'hui c'est simplement en guise
d'introduction pour pour cette cette
journée c'est encore un peu rebelle de
parler comme ça puisque la gamification
l'entreprise on est vraiment au tout
début
aujourd'hui si vous voulez motivé votre
équipe ait commencé par une injure à un
vrai jeu bien appliquée j'en croise très
très peu très très peu
mais le pari qu'on fait c'est que ça va
changer et si vous avez des
responsabilités dans votre entreprise
est une équipe à gérer je vous invite et
je vous encourage à prendre les devants
et à réfléchir autrement et commence à
réfléchir par une mécanique de jeu
ils vérifiaient que ça fonctionne parce
qu'on vérifie tous les jours voilà je
vous remercie